well I think that's a myth there I think
there's a myth out there that if you are
a hyperactive or ADHD kid ritalin or
Ritalin like medications are going to
work on you differently then they will
on the normal population and that's what
it is it's a myth it's inaccurate so for
all of us whenever we would take one of
these medicines your dopamine and
norepinephrine is clogged are going to
be more readily available in your brain
you will be more focused you will be
more attentive you also might be a
little more uptight and a little more
hyper vigilant and when you take any
medicine there's a cost-benefit ratio
any time you take a medicine there's a
potential side effect so if you don't
have ADHD and you're going to take this
medicine any psychostimulant any type of
drug like this is going to increase your
heart rate it may elevate your blood
pressure it will decrease your appetite
those things are side effects that are
unnecessary if your dopamine and
norepinephrine levels are normal in the
same way that if you take to any aspirin
it will thin your platelets which might
be good but might be bad and if you take
too much aspirin you can actually get an
ulcer so this is something that every
time you get prescribed a medicine a
doctor's thinking about what the
cost-benefit ratio is the important part
for us to remember is that when someone
with ADHD gets these medicines they get
closer to what a normal typical brain
response is so that they look less
hyperactive they look more attentive
therefore they're less impulsive they
are able to do what they're capable of
doing it doesn't increase your IQ points
it doesn't make you smarter it lets you
get to the IQ points that you do have
and therefore while you're never as
attentive as a typical or normal
individual and you never stop moving
around
and stay as still as a typical normal
you are more in the normal range that
permits you to be more contemplative
insightful and therefore get in touch
with or use your intelligence
well I think there are other side
effects so for instance particularly if
you take dexedrine which is a more
potent version of Ritalin slightly
different different chemical structure
there is no doubt that you will also get
a slight rise in your mood you will feel
somewhat more euphoric and you will feel
more expansive and therefore if you
start taking that medicine on a regular
basis when you don't have it you very
possibly will feel a crash or you will
feel down and therefore that's the
potential side effect that could be
quite serious that you become used to it
or become almost addicted to the
sensation of feeling good when it's not
necessary to cause you to focus or you
don't need it for extended attention